bien isabelle mergault vous êtes prête
pour un anti portrait chinois
vous connaissez le portrait chinoise
elle est très inquiète et je la sors pas
souvent un petit
d'ailleurs j'ai remarqué qu'elle ne
sortait qu'avec voulons mais on la voit
jamais sur un plateau télé en jam et
bien c'est une manière très juste très
fier et très heureux de l'avoir donc
fait partie avec lui très gentil
jusqu'ici ça va je vous donnerai bien
foutu qu'elle jouait bien tout va bien
bon alors vous connaissez le portrait
chinois donc ces sites étaient une fleur
c'est l'anti portrait chinois évidemment
c'est beaucoup plus négatif que ça si
vous étiez et je saurai si vous étiez un
comique pas drôle mais ce serait moi
quand je suis dans des émissions télé
une tout le monde attend que ce soit
voilà comme tous les comics rue rhin un
peu mine de rien et si vous étiez un
animal malodorant alors là mon chien
comme bien sûr mais après son 100 points
et plus encore
les jetons firme
il s'appelle comment steve est elle
s'appelle vives fécondation in vitro et
transporte pas ces embrouilles à mr
aulas si vous étiez une émission de tf1
instaurerait la mire si vous étiez une
maladie honteuse
une alopécie brutal se perdrait tous mes
poils sera sauve nous resterait que mon
défaut brand monde fou sur la langue
si vous étiez une manière de mourir bas
plutôt que nourrir dans un dernier
soupir je mourrai dans un dernier soupir
en eau
si vous étiez un fardeau pour vos
proches
c'est pas de proches si vous étiez un
film qui fait pleurer alors là sans
hésitation vercingétorix et christophe
lambert
on est d'accord
un médicament un cas c'est un gros casse
n ya qu ici de son époque
vous pourrez les aigris médias si vous
étiez un crime un ice cream waouh si
vous y étiez une partie du corps pas
indispensable double menton
si vous étiez une coiffure ratez rien du
gigolo à une choucroute zarac une
voiture française